BARTON ZWIEBACH: Today's
subject is momentum space.
We're going to kind of discover
the relevance of momentum
space.
We've been working
with wave functions
that tell you the
probabilities for finding
a particle in a given
position and that's sometimes
called coordinate
space or position space
representations of
quantum mechanics,
and we just talked about
wave functions that
tell you about probabilities
to find a particle in a given
position.
But as we've been
seeing with momentum,
there's a very intimate relation
between momentum and position,
and today we're going to
develop the ideas that
lead you to think
about momentum space
in a way that is quite
complimentary to coordinate
space.
Then we will be able to
talk about expectation
values of operators
and we're going
to be moved some steps into
what is called interpretation
of quantum mechanics.
So operators have expectations
values in quantum mechanism--
they are defined
in a particular way
and that will be
something we're going
to be doing in the second
part of the lecture.
In the final part
of the lecture,
we will consider
the time dependence
of those expectation
values, which is again,
the idea of dynamics--
if you want to understand how
your system evolves in time,
the expectation value--
the things that you measure--
may change in time
and that's part
of the physics of the
problem, so this will tie
into the Schrodinger equation.
So we're going to begin
with momentum space.
So we'll call this
uncovering momentum space.
And for much of what
I will be talking
about in the first
half of the lecture,
time will not be relevant--
so time will become relevant
later.
So I will be writing
wave functions that
don't show the
time, but the time
could be put there everywhere
and it would make no difference
whatsoever.
So you remember these
Fourier transform statements
that we had that a wave
function of x we could put time,
but they said let's
suppress time.
It's a superposition
of plane waves.
So there is a superposition
of plane waves
and we used it last time to
evolve wave packets and things
like that.
And the other side of Fourier's
theorem is that phi of k
can be written by a pretty
similar integral, in which you
put psi of x, you change
the sign in the exponential,
and of course,
integrate now over x.
Now this is the wave
function you've always
learned about first, and
then this wave function,
as you can see, is encoded
by phi of k as well.
If you know phi of
k, you know psi of x.
And so this phi of k has the
same information in principle
as psi of x--
it tells you everything
that you need to know.
We think of it as
saying, well, phi of k
has the same
information as psi of x.
And the other thing
we've said about phi of k
is that it's the weight with
which you're superposing plane
waves to reconstruct psi of x.
The Fourier transform
theorem is a representation
of the wave function in terms of
a superposition of plane waves,
and here, it's the
coefficient of the wave that
accompanies each exponential.
So phi of k is the
weight of the plane
waves in the superposition.
So one thing we want to do is
to understand even deeper what
phi of k can mean.
And so in order to do that,
we need a technical tool.
Based on these
equations, one can
derive a way of representing
this object that we
call the delta function.
Delta functions are pretty
useful for manipulating objects
and Fourier transforms,
so we need them.
So let's try to obtain what
is called the delta function
statement.
And this is done by
trying to apply these two
equations simultaneously.
Like, you start
with psi of x, it's
written in terms of
phi of k, but then what
would happen if you
would substitute
the value of phi of k in here?
What kind of equation you get?
What you get is an equation
for a delta function.
So you begin with psi of x
over square root of 2 pi,
and I'll write it
dk e to the ikx,
and now, I want
to write phi of k.
So I put phi of k--
1 over square root
of 2 pi integral psi,
and now I have to
be a little careful.
In here in the second integral,
x is a variable of integration,
it's a dummy variable.
It doesn't have any
physical meaning, per se--
it disappears after
the integration.
Here, x represents a point
where we're evaluating the wave
function, so I just cannot
copy the same formula here
because it would be confusing,
it should be written with
a different x and x-prime.
Because that x certainly
has nothing to do with the x
we're writing here.
So here it is, we've
written now this integral.
And let's rewrite it
still differently.
We'll write as
integral dx-prime.
We'll change the orders of
integration with impunity.
If you're trying to be very
rigorous mathematically,
this is something
you worry about.
In physics problems
that we deal with,
it doesn't make a difference.
So here we have dx-prime,
psi of x-prime, then
a 1 over 2 pi integral dk e
to the ik x minus x-prime.
So this is what the
integral became.
And you look at it and you
say, well, here is psi of x,
and it's equal to the
integral over x-prime
of psi of x-prime times
some other function
of x and x-prime.
This is a function of x minus
x-prime, or x and x-prime
if you wish.
It doesn't depend on
k, k is integrated.
And this function,
if you recognize it,
it's what we call
a delta function.
It's a function that,
multiplied with an integral,
evaluates the integrand
at a particular point.
So this is a delta function,
delta of x-prime minus x.
That is a way these
integrals then would work.
That is, when you
integrate over x-prime--
when you have x-prime
minus something,
then the whole integral
is the integrand
evaluated at the point where we
say the delta function fires.
So the consistency of
these two equations
means that for all
intents and purposes,
this strange integral
is a representation
of a delta function.
So we will write it down.
I can do one thing here, but--
it's kind of here you see
the psi of x-prime minus x,
but here you see
x minus x-prime.
But that's sign, in
fact, doesn't matter.
It's not there.
You can get rid of it.
Because if in this integral,
you can let K goes to minus k,
and then the dk changes sign,
the order of integration
changes sign, and they
cancel each other.
And the effect is
that you change
the sign in the exponents, so
if you let k goes to minus k,
the integral just becomes
1 over 2 pi integral dk e
to the ik x-prime minus x.
So we'll say that
this delta function
is equal to this thing,
exploiting this sign ambiguity
that you can always have.
So I'll write it
again in the way
most people write the formula,
which is at this moment,
switching x and x-prime.
So you will write this
delta of x minus x-prime
is 1 over 2 pi integral from
infinity to minus infinity dk
e to the ik x minus x-prime.
So this is a pretty
useful formula
and we need it all the time
that we do Fourier transforms
as you will see very soon.
It's a strange integral, though.
If you have x equal to x-prime,
this is 0 and you get infinity.
So it's a function,
it's sort of 0--
when x minus x-prime
is different from 0,
somehow all these
waves superimpose to 0.
But when x is equal to
x-prime, it blows up.
So it's does the right thing,
it morally does the right thing,
but it's a singular
kind of expression
and we therefore
manipulate it with care
and typically, we use
it inside of integrals.
So it's a very nice formula,
we're going to need it,
and it brings here for the
first time in our course,
I guess, the delta functions.
And this is something if
should-- if you have not
ever play without
the functions, this
may be something interesting
to ask in recitation
or you can try to prove, for
example, just like we show
that delta of minus x
is the same as delta
of x, the delta of
a being a number
times x is 1 over absolute
value of a times delta of x.
Those are two simple
properties of delta functions
and you could practice by
just trying to prove them--
for example, use this integral
representation to show them.